good morning to you good morning to you  so i was just googling what national day  it is and it turns out it is national  fluffernutter day excuse me we both  weren't really sure what that was are  you like to see that on television  fluffernutter yeah so  sorry everybody at home do you know what  it is if you do let us know um but i  googled it and it turns out that it's a  sandwich with peanut butter and  marshmallow just kind of squished  together  breakfast of champions i i've never had  this before nate have you had a  fluffernutter before i have rejected  that fluffernutter  i have been offered a fluffernutter and  i politely declined